أنا هنا في فيغاس لحضور عطلة نهاية
الأسبوع الافتتاحية لـSphere، حيث يقول بعض الأشخاص
إنها المكان الترفيهي
للمستقبل وسيعمل YouTube
هنا في وقت لاحق الليلة. لقد
رأيتكما تعيشان ربما ست أو سبع
مرات ولم أرهما من قبل  بهذه الطريقة
كتبت مقالًا لـ CNN والذي
ظهر مباشرة بعد عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في الرابع من يوليو
عندما أضاءت شركة Sphere أضواءها الخارجية
للمرة الأولى، وقد شعرت بالفضول
بشأن هذا المكان منذ ذلك الحين، لذلك أرسلوا
لي دعوة يسألونني عما إذا كنت أرغب في
الخروج و  تحقق من عطلة نهاية الأسبوع الافتتاحية
[تصفيق] على
استعداد للتوجه إلى مقاعدنا التي تجلس فيها ويبدو الأمر
مستقبليًا للغاية، هناك
مستويات متعددة ولكنها لا
تبدو فريدة حقًا حتى تذهب إلى
الجزء المسرحي نفسه
[موسيقى] لقد خرجوا
وبدأوا  تشغيل
أغنيتهم ​​الأولى ثم
بدأوا تدريجيًا في عرض الصور على هذه
الشاشة الضخمة خلفهم، فهي تملأ
مجال رؤيتك بالكامل، يبدو المسرح
صغيرًا مقارنة بالمسرح على شكل قرص دوار، حيث
يوجد طبق دائري
حيث كانت الفرقة تقف  وكانت بانا
تدور حول نفسها في وقت ما، ولكن
كعضو من الجمهور، فأنت لا تعرف دائمًا
أين تنظر، هل تنظر إلى الفرقة على
المسرح أم تنظر إلى الأعلى أو تنظر حولك
إلى العناصر المرئية من حولك، لقد
تأثرت بالصوت  الجودة لقد
أجريت مقابلات مع بعض رواد الحفلات الموسيقية
بعد العرض وقال أحد الأشخاص إنه
عادة ما يحضر سدادات الأذن إلى الحفلات الموسيقية
لأن الصوت مرتفع للغاية لكنه شعر أنه
لا يحتاج إليها،
إنه بالتأكيد شيء لن
أنساه أبدًا وهو رائع جدًا سأقوله
رغم ذلك في بعض الأحيان
كل ما تحتاجه هو فرقة موسيقية رائعة في ذروة لعبتها،
إذا كنت مهتمًا حقًا بالموسيقى
والموسيقى رائعة والجمهور معجب بها
وهذه الطاقة موجودة، فأنت لا
تحتاج بالضرورة إلى كل الأجراس والصفارات الأخرى